[Music]
emergency crews to stations
get back to Tanaka time to come here
with every man he's gone
from James Bond movies to The
Incredibles the notion of secret
dwellings inside mountains has captured
imaginations for decades but 50 years
ago in Scotland a power company decided
that they could use the inside of one
particular Mountain for a very different
kind of use Roxanna saberi went to
Scotland to find out more
beside the clear waters of a Scottish
Lake known as laka soars Ben crew again
a mountain rising to over three and a
half thousand feet masking a marble of
engineering it does look very James
bond-ish we traveled through a tunnel
over a half a mile long
to emerge in a turbine Hall carved into
rock buzzing with Machinery this is the
heart of a hydroelectric plant that
engineer Ian kinnard says points to the
future of renewable energy
8.50 gigawatts of storage energy is a
maximum to put that in context that's
probably equivalent to about 145 000
Tesla Model 3s and sitting fully charged
that's how much energy we store who
calculated that
that energy comes from water 1300 feet
up the mountain can you explain where we
are up here what is this absolutely in
front of you you have Crook and
Reservoir which is held back by kroken
Dam Sarah Cameron who manages a nearby
Visitor Center says the reservoir fills
up with rain and water pumped up from
lock off when the water is released from
the reservoir it flows down to the power
plant and through the force of gravity
turns its turbines so it's a cycle it's
a cycle exactly absolutely
when demand for energy goes up these
turbines kick into high gear within 30
seconds they can provide enough
electricity to power 800 000 homes
compare that to coal-fired plants which
can take hours to spark to life the UN
says globally hydropower supplies around
17 percent of electricity though it
makes up much less in the UK and the us
some environmentalists say it's needed
to help the world transition to
renewable energy
but they add dams can disrupt Wildlife
the team at crookin says it's tried to
minimize any impact by blending into the
landscape as much as possible and by
using screens to prevent marine life
from being sucked from the reservoir how
well it meditate Royal inauguration a
pull of the lever and the great machines
were turning generating power for the
industrial lowlands a celebrated feat of
construction that started in 1959 it
took around 4 000 workers six years to
build kruken you can still see some of
the board pools before the drilled and
plastered
next year the British company Drax hopes
to begin Excavating an estimated 2
million more tons of rock to expand the
plant you know it's Testament to those
that built it back in the the late 1950s
and early 60s you know 60 years later
we're still operating this plant and
it's you know more needed than ever
before they say to help Scotland wean
itself off of fossil fuels the ready to
move mountains again
for CBS Saturday morning Roxanna saberi
Argyle Scotland
so cool yeah and I just say that cool
and nice last lines Roxanna I like yeah
and great great name of the town Argyle
and great accent I almost got a little
lost in the accent where I was like wait
pay attention yeah
yeah very interesting yeah